[Music]
stephen is with us in indianapolis hi
steven welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you great man what's up
hey one just want to say a big fan you
guys got me and my wife out of debt over
the last couple years so uh following
your method so i just want to say i'm a
huge fan of yours and uh thanks for
taking my call well done um
yes sir on this one now i'm calling for
my sister she is historically bad with
money and she's a little help um
she had a car
had it paid off in cash at one point and
needed like three thousand dollars worth
of work so she did something i don't
agree with she traded in
got a loan at a buy here pay here for a
car that's not even worth its own weight
now
and now this car
needs about
2500 worth of work the car is only worth
about 3 000 and she owes 10 000 on this
loan so my question is how can she get
out of this car into something more
reliable without taking out another loan
and rolling negative equity and going
into debt
she's screwed
i know yeah
i mean there's not a move here uh she's
gonna be in debt she's ten thousand
dollars in debt and she has an asset
that's not worth two thousand bucks
right did i understand that right yeah
yeah
and so she has an eight thousand dollar
hole
and there's the only way to cover that
is eight thousand dollars and that's
going to come from somewhere
so um
yeah obviously we're not gonna do a deal
with these people again so
but
let me tell you what they will do
it's a buy here pay here
their uh
repo rate
back onto that lot
is very very
high because of this situation
because people get that people
instead of asking a question like you're
asking they get in these situations and
they just drive up and toss the keys in
the window and keep walking
and um and that's standard in that
business so you know like
let's just say among a regular car like
you go to a ford dealer and get a ford
motor company ford motor credit loan
let's just say that the repo rate there
is three percent
the repo rate in a tote the note lot is
probably 40 percent
you see what i'm saying
and the reason is is they're selling the
car for twice as much as it's worth
and they're got payments on it and then
it's a piece of crap car and they end up
breaking anyway and they get in the same
mess and so they're used to dealing with
her my point is they probably will
negotiate that eight down if she goes
somewhere else and gets a loan gives
them real money like they will for sure
okay so i would send her like to the
credit union
and uh off you know offer them once she
gets a loan arranged with the credit
union maybe she gets a five thousand
dollar loan and uh offer them the car
back
and the uh
and two thousand dollars
they'll probably take it
take the other take the other three
thousand and buy a car anywhere else but
a place like that
loan to do that yeah go go get a 5 000
loan at the credit union we're getting
rid of a 10 000 loan with this
transaction you following me
yep i'm following you so i'm i'm not
borrowing i mean i'm borrowing money but
we've already got borrowed money we're
just making it better
so you take you you go then you go over
there are you in town the same town with
her
no again this goes back to her being
that with money she ended up moving down
to texas where the cost of living is a
lot more than is here in indianapolis so
she's is she got any family in that town
where she is
no unfortunately both our parents passed
away and that's another reason she
wanted to move just to kind of get away
and restart because um
just having dealt with these folk all
the time for the last 30 years
uh
here's here's a best-case scenario i'm
not sure we can pull it off but if she
can go get a 5 000 loan at the credit
union
uh buy an airline ticket and go down
there
get in get her car and her and drive
over to that lot
and you sit down in front of that
manager
it creates a different vibe in that
world than her doing it
okay and you can go ahead and get up in
his grill if you want for being a crook
as a part of this transaction and go
look dude if you think you're getting
ten thousand dollars out of this broke
woman you is what's known as confused
and so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna give you this car back that's a
piece of crap that you ripped her off
with in the first place and two thousand
dollars and you're gonna smile and
you're gonna like it aren't you
and that's
you can do that a whole lot better than
she can do it in that world you
following me
i'm following you and uh i'm serious
that that's about the verbiage and the
attitude i would use i'm not being
bombastic
because that you're you're in a rough
and tumble world there
so go go in there uh with that kind of
you know swagger and just go look we're
not doing this
you screwed her and so now you're gonna
make it right and you're gonna make so
you're still gonna make a profit you got
your stupid car back and you got some
money you go on lo you live another day
and you let her go and this otherwise
we're gonna have a real problem here and
we're gonna have to get lawyers involved
and we're gonna have to get oh man it's
just gonna be messy and none of us want
to do that so let's just to get us a
deal done right here
okay if you can pull that if you can
pull that off in your schedule and buy a
200 plane ticket fly down and help her
handle it um
it sounds like i'm being sexist i'm not
but that world is right you're gonna get
a different you're gonna get a different
thing when you walk in there than she
will
and uh because you know they saw her
coming the first time
and she's gonna have to reset in their
brain for them to not see her coming
again and that that's that's what we're
dealing with well their entire business
practice is built on desperation well
and intimidation right yeah so we just
flip that on them a little
let's have a little discussion about
this
oh my goodness yeah that's that's the
thing so yeah
yeah
so here's the thing when you're guys
when you're looking at stuff like this
in
uh lower income real estate
and lower income
uh which is what tote the note is always
associated with
uh what what the the deal is not the
interest rate that they're charging you
it's that they're giving you terms
when no one else will give you terms
they'll put you on payments when no one
else will put you on payments and so
they're making a bazillion dollars by
changing the price of the item
not by charging a 30 interest rate they
may only charge a 20 interest rate
subprime interest rate but then double
the price of the car
you buy a house
i used to have friends that would sell
houses in these uh low-income
neighborhoods and they sell the house on
weekly payments
pay payments weekly
and
with nothing down or 500 down you could
buy a house with weekly payments and all
the people heard was 500 down and weekly
that's all they heard they didn't hear
that the you know this house that's
worth in those days forty thousand
forty thousand bucks is being sold to
them for sixty uh
and the interest rate sounded pretty
good so until you factor in the fact
that they're over charging for the
actual item so much when you put that
back in as an interest rate now you got
a 400 interest rate i heard there's a
crackdown on those total notes interest
rates and i guess that's the that's the
way you fix it that's the way you fix it
that's it's not us
if it's just the price is ridiculous
yeah and people aren't they don't even
look at the price right oh they're
they're just desperate
can i get desperate intimidated scared
and and it's almost like that caller
earlier where the guy thinks that
they're doing him a favor that's right
and uh it's it's a it's it's a
disastrous
scenario so same thing with like rent to
own yeah you know
if
if you need to rent your washer and
dryer
you don't need to buy a washer and dryer
yeah
period
you know and someone's taking you and so
here's the thing
you can kind of look too at the
groupings of these offerings if you
drive down the main drag of a lower
income end of town
all the things that you see there
are just about rip-offs the predatory
yeah title pawn
pawn
uh
rent to own
[Music]
tote the note um you know it's all right
there and it's every one of them are
screwing you yeah and so and same thing
if you're watching tv
and your investment is in the same place
as a snuggie and a walk-in bathtub then
you probably don't have a good
investment